[Musik]
guten Abend es ist ein spannender Abend
deutschland hat gewählt jetzt müssen
Verlierer und Siege Verantwortung
übernehmen die einen für ihre Fehler und
die anderen für ihre Wahlversprechen wie
wird Deutschland in den kommenden Jahren
in den kommenden vier Jahren regiert das
wollen wir wissen von diesen Gästen
Norbert Röttgen Mitglied im
CDU-Präsidium
Sigmar Gabriel ehemaliger
SPD-Vorsitzender
die Autoren und Mitglied der Grünen
Marina Weisband
Alexander Graf Lambsdorff Fraktionsvize
der FDP
die Journalistin Anja Meyer
und Robin Alexander von der Welt
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt die Gäste dieser Sendung
ausgesprochen herzlich klasse dass sie
mit dabei sind heute abend erste Frage
geht an Robin Alexander geschätzten
Journalistenkollegen der Welt Herr
Alexander wer gewonnen hat ist vorne wer
vorne ist hat gewonnen so einfach ist es
diesmal nicht haben wir gelernt nee
diesem hatte der Wähler das erste Wort
aber nicht das letzte Wort und Olaf
Scholz liegt noch vorne aber mit einer
kleinen Marge und die werden erstmal
alle verhandeln und wer sich dann am
Ende nach vorne verhandelt bleibt noch
abzusehen Anja Meyer
journalisten-kollegen genauso geschätzt
sie haben gesagt Frau Meier dass die der
Scholz Zug dass sie den Zug von Olaf
Scholz nicht haben kommen sehen jetzt
ist er da und aber nun jetzt marschiert
er ins Kanzleramt oder eigentlich doch
nicht ja das wissen wir am Ende dieses
Jahr dieses Tages leider immer noch
nicht also es wird spannend weil die
beiden es gibt ja nicht so ein wirklich
klaren Abstand zwischen den beiden
Spitzenkandidaten deshalb kann man
einfach auch noch nicht sagen also man
kann schon sagen der eine hat kräftig
dazu geworden der andere hat kräftig
verloren und einer liegt vorne und einer
liegt leichter hinter aber das ist jetzt
diese diese Möglichkeit einer Chance
nicht aus den Händen gibt das hat
mehrere Gründe über die wir
wahrscheinlich heute auch noch sprechen
werden wir unter Garantie machen und
schalten jetzt mal zunächst fröhlich
nach Goslar zu Sigmar Gabriel ehemaligen
Parteivorsitzenden und Vizekanzler ade
dieses Landes Gabriel sie haben gesagt
die SPD hat vor allem dazu gewonnen weil
die anderen so schlecht waren und jetzt
wird ausgerechnet dieser schwache Armin
Laschet möglicherweise Kanzler
aus dass Olaf Scholz eine gute Chance
hat ganzer zu werden am Ende sind
Mehrheiten im Deutschen Bundestag nötig
und das sind keine mathematischen
Mehrheiten alleine es braucht politische
Mehrheiten also Parteien die
zusammenfinden und genug Gemeinsamkeit
entwickeln damit sie über die Dauer von
vier Jahren eine stabile Regierung
stellen können und das wird man jetzt
sehen wer das am Ende schafft das ist
heute Abend noch nicht ganz klar aber
die Aufholjagd die der Olaf Scholz
hingelegt hat die ist schon
beeindruckend gewesen und wenn sie sagen
die anderen waren so schlecht was war so
schlecht an dem Wahlkampf der Union
naja erstmal würde ich sagen es waren
weitgehend politikfreier
Bundestagswahlkampf das galt
wahrscheinlich eher für alle aber das
natürlich der Armin Laschet alle Chancen
liegen gelassen hat zu zeigen dass er
sag mal ein guter politischer Manager
ist zum Beispiel in der
schlimmen Flutkatastrophe wo er im
eigenen Land keine Zustimmung fand
eigentlich auch nicht versucht hat
überhaupt Politik klarzumachen mir ist
kein Satz von ihm in Erinnerung
geblieben der irgendwie
ihn ausgedrückt hätte und dagegen dann
eben am Ende wenn es nicht um Politik
geht wenn Menschen nicht ob politische
Kontroversen sehen dann fragen sie sich
wer ist die bessere Person und da hatte
Scholz offensichtlich deutlich bessere
Karten aber das ist das Ergebnis wenn
man nicht über Politik redet dann bleibt
der Mensch ja nichts anderes übrig als
sich die Frage zu stellen wer könnte es
denn personell am besten das sind ja
immer eigentlich beides Politik und
Personen aber
ich kann nicht sehen dass in diesem
Wahlkampf wesentliche politische
Kontroversen stattgefunden haben ja das
werden wir hier auch gleich noch mal
diskutieren ich höre gerade aus der
Regie dass wir ins Willy brandt-haus
noch mal ganz kurz schalten können da
steht jetzt die Ministerpräsidentin von
Rheinland-Pfalz Malu Dreyer Frau Dreier
einen schönen guten Abend natürlich zu
ihnen wir wollten ganz kurz noch mal
ihre Pegelstände abholen 25 Prozent sind
es für Olaf Scholz auch einen
Prozentpunkt jetzt nach allen
Hochrechnungen vor der Union damit hat
er gewonnen aber das kann ein Sieg sein
der ihm nichts nutzt
grüße Sie Frau Illner nein es ist ein
wunderbarer Tag heute für die SPD zum
zweiten Mal jetzt seit 2002 sind wir
wieder stärkste Partei geworden und das
freut uns natürlich total wir haben auch
sehr hart an dieser Frage gearbeitet ein
großer großer Sieg für Olaf Scholz und
für eine geschlossene Partei insofern
gehe ich ganz stark davon aus dass wir
diesen Regierungsauftrag natürlich
annehmen werden und wir dann auch zu
Gesprächen einladen werden und suchen
werden um eine stabile Mehrheit für
Deutschland zu finden er hat jetzt im
Grunde genommen noch eine Option weil
das rot-grün-rote Bündnis nicht mehr in
Frage kommt oder denken Sie überhaupt
auch noch über eine große Koalition nach
das darf man nicht vergessen zu fragen
naja heute abend reden wir erstmal gar
nicht über Koalition heute Abend freuen
wir uns als Sozialdemokraten der wurden
ja schon von vielen abgeschrieben dass
wir es wieder geschafft haben als
Volkspartei bis sichtbar zu werden und
man muss schon auch sehr klar sagen wir
haben auch große Themen Gefahren in
diesem Wahlkampf also ich teile das
nicht dass dieser Wahlkampf nicht
politisch war und wenn man sieht wer in
dieser Wahl gewonnen hat dann ist es die
SPD es sind aber auch die Grünen sehr
deutlich es sind fortschrittliche
Mehrheiten die Menschen wollen eine
Veränderung das ist für mich vollkommen
klar und wenn man über die Kanzlerfrage
nachdenkt dann darf man aus meiner Sicht
nicht verkennen dass die Mehrheit der
Bürger und Bürgerinnen sehr sehr
deutlich ausgesagt haben dass sie nicht
Armin Laschet im Kanzleramt sehen wollen
sondern Olaf Scholz und daran müssen wir
vereint mit den Kräften Arbeiten für die
eben eine Koalition denkbar ist und es
ist ganz sicher die Ampel und solche
Gespräche wird es dann in Zukunft auch
geben müssen die Ampel und damit ist es
wahrscheinlich die Option die für ihn
jetzt auch möglich ist und für die SPD
damit er wird Grünen und der FDP etwas
anbieten müssen was wird das sein
das kann ich Ihnen heute gar nicht sagen
ich finde ehrlich gesagt auch dass das
gar kein Zugang zu einer Koalition ist
sondern ein in einer Koalition müssen
alle Parteien bereit sein auch ein Stück
zu geben und zu nehmen ist ganz klar
jeder muss sich und sein Profil auch
wiedererkennen können aber man braucht
man allererster Stelle erstmal das
gemeinsame vertrauen dass man
Deutschland nach vorne bringen kann das
ist der Anspruch denn eigentlich alle
Parteien sich auch stellen die jetzt in
diesem Wahlkampf gerungen haben und wir
wollen Zukunft gestalten das bedeutet
vor allem dass wir den Klimawandel
bekämpfen wollen mehr Klimaschutz wagen
können und das auch sozial ausgewogen
und gerecht gestalten insofern es bleibt
dabei man muss Gespräche suchen man muss
Vertrauen bilden damit eine Koalition
auch stabil sein kann und dann wird man
darüber sprechen müssen wer kann was
geben damit es am Ende dann auch eine
gesichtswarnung Koalition wird die Stadt
Biel ist für vier Jahre was wenn sich
die Grünen und die FDP Frau Dreier meine
letzte Frage tatsächlich erstmal vorab
miteinander ins Benehmen setzen und
verhandeln und sich am Ende für ihren
lieblingskanzler entscheiden und das ist
gegebenenfalls der schwächere und der
heißt Armin Laschet
ich bin heute abend erstmal ganz ganz
gelassen weil jede Partei wird sich die
Frage stellen müssen was wollen
eigentlich Bürger und Bürgerinnen und da
ist doch die Meinung total klar was Olaf
Scholz betrifft und Armin Laschet und
insofern denke ich sollte man heute
Abend einfach den Abend genießen am
nächsten morgen geht es dann weiter auch
mit den Fragen die werden Gespräche
geführt Manu Dreyer ganz herzlichen Dank
ins Willy brandt-haus da wird jetzt
offensichtlich nur gut und wir danken
noch mal und sind bei Norbert Röttgen
Herr Röttgen hallo schlechtes Ergebnis
ziemlich schlechtes Ergebnis und es ist
jetzt egal weil man am liebsten regieren
möchte nein das Ergebnis ist nicht egal
wir haben ein Ergebnis erreicht als
Partei mit dem wir absolut nicht
zufrieden sind ist nicht akzeptabel und
das wirft doch eine
verantwortungsaufgabe überbringt das mit
sich nämlich die Frage Volkspartei CDU
und da ist klare Arbeitsauftrag da
unsere gesellschaftliche Verankerung ist
nicht so wie wir sie akzeptieren können
wenn wir Volkspartei bleiben das ist ein
ganz klarer auftragen und das andere ist
das ist hier ja auch schon besprochen
worden wir sind jetzt was die
Regierungsbildung anbelangt sind und die
Union und die SPD ungefähr gleich auf
und darum ist das jetzt auch nicht eine
Frage von Personen sondern ist eine
Frage ob Parteien
Übereinstimmung finden bei den Fragen
die Sigmar Gabriel glaube ich
richtigerweise angesprochen hat von
denen ich auch meine dass es mich
besorgt ist dass wir zu wenig über die
Fragen wirklich debattiert haben ist
eine große Sorge weil wir vor enormen
Aufgaben stehen enormen
Herausforderungen und die Chance die
jetzt besteht auch die Aufgabe ist dass
es jetzt gelingt wenn man spricht
wer traut sich wer hat eigentlich ein
Konzept und eine Übereinstimmung diesen
riesigen Aufgaben gerecht zu werden und
es hinzubekommen ich glaube zum Beispiel
wir haben eine internationale Krisenlage
die gewaltig ist gewaltig ist
eine der Fragen wird sein was ist
eigentlich
Europa in fünf Jahren oder am Ende
dieses Jahrzehnts noch wert ökonomisch
technologisch und geopolitisch das ist
glaube ich eine große große Frage in der
unter die man viel bringen kann das ist
geht vom Klima von der Klimapolitik bis
zum Verhältnis zu Russland China danach
Mittlere Osten Afghanistan ist noch da
und das ist glaube ich zum Beispiel ein
Bereich wo cdu/csu Grüne und FDP groß
Übereinstimmung haben und darüber wird
jetzt gesprochen werden und da muss man
ein Bild machen am Ende was passt am
besten ich wollte sie diesen Inhalt noch
malen lassen und dieses Bild auch noch
mal lassen um dann aber dennoch zu
fragen und erstmal ganz pragmatisch zu
fragen die CSU hatte ja vor der Wahl
gesagt Alexander Dobrindt nicht in die
Fantasie würde nicht ausreichen sich
vorzustellen dass der Zweitplatzierte
eine solche Regierungskoalition anführen
kann
der
Edmund Stoiber der gleichen Meinung
andere mehr in der CSU hat die CSU in
Auffassung jetzt beigedreht
also ich fand alle Äußerungen zu zweit
platziert und was auch immer nicht sehr
hilfreich muss ich mal sagen der
gewonnen hat ich habe immer gesagt wir
haben ein klares Ziel und das ist vorne
zu sein und das ist das Beste wenn man
eine Regierung bilden möchte und
natürlich muss man das respektieren wenn
der SPD liegt stand jetzt so ein Prozent
vorne sind ein paar Sitze sie liegt also
leicht vorne das muss fließt doch in die
Bewertung wieder ein das ist völlig klar
das respektieren wir aber politisch ist
es im Grunde ein Gleichstand das glaube
ich muss man sagen
wussten aber das ist ja wir haben uns
habe ich auch eben da werde ich auch
nicht so beschönigen gar keine Frage 8
Prozent ich könnte es ihnen ausmalen in
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen in Städten
in Wahlkreisen absolut klar aber es geht
jetzt um
regierungsmehrheiten die eine
inhaltliche Basis brauchen und das wird
es jetzt sein und nicht die Entwicklung
wer kommt von wo in den Umfragen sonst
was und da sage ich auch nicht wir haben
irgendeinen Anspruch oder sonst was
sondern ich würde wirklich davon
ausgehen von den gewaltigen
Herausforderungen auf die ist noch keine
wirklichen Konzepte gibt das ist alles
auch in diesem gesamten Wahlkampf sehr
oft der Oberflächlichkeit und Sie
entdecken ist auch nicht im Konzept
ihrer Partei in den Wahlprogrammen ihrer
Partei wir müssen sie auch das ist ja
ein Vorwurf der Armin Laschet gemacht
wurde dass es im Grunde genommen keine
Aussagen zu dieser Zukunft gibt die sie
jetzt wenigstens für Europameisterschaft
für diese Kritik die ich gerade
formuliert habe an allen Parteien und
ich nehme auch die CDU nicht aus und ich
fange doch auch an zu überlegen wir
haben ja schon länger schlechte Umfragen
warum ist das eigentlich so könnten wir
nicht in der themenkompetenz in
unterschiedlichen Gebieten stärker sein
nein wir haben auch genau diesen diesen
Arbeitsauftrag und die Anforderung der
Wirklichkeit die feststehen die sind
größer als die Antworten die bislang
alle Parteien gegeben haben Robin
Alexander noch mal die Frage Ergebnis
ist wirklich schlecht und es gibt
schlechte Umfragewerte auch verträglich
für Armin Laschet um nicht zu sagen
wirklich grauenvolle Werte so ist zu
zitieren und jetzt haben die werden wir
ausgerechnet diesen Kanzlerkandidaten zu
unserem Kanzler wählen in Deutschland
das wissen wir noch nicht aber das
Interessante ist doch normalerweise
würden wir jetzt einen neuen Kanzler
kriegen und wir uns alle überlegen was
macht Olaf Scholz was macht Armin
Laschet und die würden dann einen
kleinen Partner dazu holen und dann
würde man den Grünen das dosenfund
Schenken oder der FDP würde man die
hotelsteuer schenken so ist das früher
gelaufen so wird das diesmal nicht
laufen sondern die das Interesse nicht
bei den anderen beiden jetzt ist die
Frage was macht die FDP was machen die
Grünen und dass die Grünen das Angebot
von Lindner schon angenommen haben
zuerst zu reden zeigt ja dass sie schon
verstanden haben in welcher
interessanten Position sie sind also was
Herr Röttgen sagt wir müssen über
Inhalte reden das stimmt aber die ersten
die darüber reden werden die beiden
anderen Parteien sein und das kann auch
ein verdammt interessantes Gespräch
werden also gleiche Frage wie an Malu
Dreyer gerade kann es sein die beiden
FDP und Grüne sich verständigen und
vorher verständigen und sich dann
eigentlich nachträglich noch aussuchen
mit welchen Kanzler Sie dieses also
sonst kommen Sie an einen
mieterwettbewerb und das wäre nicht gut
wenn sie wenn sie klug sind tun sie das
wäre natürlich wieder eine Chance für
die Union weil dieses Modell FDP und
Grüne reden zuerst gab es bisher nur
einmal in Schleswig-Holstein von Robert
Habeck und von Herrn und das ist dann
tatsächlich zu Jamaika geführt und das
muss nicht wieder so kommen aber dass
dieses Gespräch zuerst geführt wird das
finde ich schon nicht unschlau und dann
holen wir doch unbedingt Alexander Graf
Lambsdorff in die Runde Graf Langsdorf
das ist natürlich auch interessant die
SPD ist vorne aber egal Kurs auf Jamaika
sagt die FDP
nein was wir sagen ist dass wir uns
erstmal über unser Ergebnis freuen dass
sowieso klar und zum zweiten sagen wir
das mir wie mit allen Reden auch das ist
klar aber was Robin Alexander gerade
gesagt hat ist auch klar es ist absolut
richtig dass wir vorhaben zuerst mit den
Grünen zu reden weil das die beiden
Parteien sind die nicht abgewählt worden
sind die beide gewonnen haben das sind
zwei Parteien wo ich Herrn Röttgen
deutlich widersprechen würde wir haben
Konzepte für die Zukunft sie
unterscheiden sich und da müssen wir
einfach miteinander reden unter
Liberalen und untergrünen wer kann wem
wo entgegenkommen und dann werden wir
mit dem Ergebnis mit den anderen schauen
was man dann erreichen kann mit welchem
Partner ob das jetzt die
Sozialdemokraten sind die ja wirklich
ein sehr tollen Wahlkampf hingelegt
haben kann man gar nicht anders sagen
oder die Union bei der man das wirklich
nicht behaupten kann am Ende des Tages
wird entscheidend sein wer wird die
nächsten vier Jahre für Deutschland
erfolgreich gestalten können und FDP und
Grüne werden die Gespräche dazu beginnen
Marina weißband ist bei uns nicht grünen
Mitglied natürlich korrekterweise zu
formulieren
bekannt logischerweise als große
auskennerin in Sachen Digitalisierung
und Bildung sie waren auf der
Abschlusskundgebung von Robert Habeck
und Annalena baerbock mit dabei
welches der Grünen Ziele ist nicht
erreicht worden ich meine wir haben das
historisch beste Wahlergebnis
eingefahren der Grünen auf Bundesebene
aber wie das so ist ist ähnlich wie mit
dem mit den Maßnahmen gegen den
Klimawandel manchmal ist das historisch
beste nicht gut genug wir hätten mehr
erwarten können aber wir haben eine
Basis gebaut und wir haben also ich
finde die Grünen haben tatsächlich ein
fantastischen Wahlkampf hingelegt und
also ist jetzt tatsächlich nicht eine
Riesenchance auch vermasselt
nein also ja ja es ist ein Riesenchance
die wir jetzt nicht haben und das ist
natürlich die Chance auf eine
Kanzlerschaft und damit die Katastrophe
uns zu rollt jetzt noch wirklich mit
Macht steuern also wenn das die letzte
Regierung ist die etwas an der
Klimakatastrophe aufhört ist in vier
Jahren natürlich exponentiell teurer das
gilt aber nicht nur für die Grünen das
gilt dafür alle Parteien je länger wir
jetzt warten und Däumchen drehen desto
teurer wird es desto mehr
Wahlversprechen auch in Sachen
Liberalismus auch in Sachen Freiheit
auch in Sachen Sicherheit werden wir den
BürgerInnen gegenüber brechen müssen das
heißt jetzt gilt es mit der gesamt mit
dem gesamten Rückenwind den wir bekommen
haben in diese Verhandlungen zu gehen
und die Ziele durchzusetzen die jetzt
einfach notwendig sind und da stimme ich
Herrn Röttgen zu der wird Außenpolitik
eine riesige Rolle spielen da werden
Investitionen Infrastruktur Bildung und
Digitalisierung eine riesige Rolle
spielen und da sehe ich mit der FDP zum
Beispiel durchaus auch Spielraum aber
nochmal die Frage Frau Weißmann was wäre
nötig und was wäre möglich gewesen
was wäre nötig gewesen nötig wäre
wahrscheinlich gewesen dass vorher man
kam das woher man kann ja gegen Frühling
Umfragen hätte ich nichts fände ich cool
wäre sehr viel leichter gewesen dann zu
sagen wir machen jetzt tatsächlich eine
sozialverträgliche Klimapolitik wir
investieren in Bildung wie investieren
irgendwie in erneuerbare Energien wir
schaffen Arbeitsplätze dadurch aber ich
glaube es ist jetzt nicht unmöglich denn
der Job der wähler:innen ist ja jetzt
nicht vorbei nur weil sie ihr Kreuz
gemacht haben jetzt kommen die
Koalitionsverhandlungen und jetzt kommt
der spannende Teil diese
Koalitionsverhandlungen zwischen den
verschiedenen Parteien sind so
chancenreich es kommt nicht auf die
Farben an zwischen denen sie geführt
werden sondern es kommt auf die Personen
an und auf deren Überzeugungen vor
welchem Hintergrund sie geführt werden
an dieser Stelle haben alle wähler:innen
noch mal die Chance zu gucken wer führt
die Koalitionsverhandlungen wer zieht
jetzt in den Bundestag was sind deren
E-Mail-Adressen und briefadressen und
Faxnummern und ihnen zu sagen was
wichtig ist was für sie bedeutsam ist
wir haben auf eine
nachträgliche Wahl um sich damit auch an
diesen Verhandlungen noch mal zu
beteiligen es geht da nicht um Wahl
sondern es geht da um Artikulation von
inhaltlichen Interessen wir haben jetzt
eine Wahl gesehen die von Herrn Scholz
und Herrn Laschet relativ Inhalts oder
unter inhaltsvermeidung geführt wurde
und diese Inhalte jetzt noch
einzubringen wie wir es vor zwei Tagen
auf dieser gigantischen Demonstration
überall in deutschen Städten gesehen
haben das finde ich noch mal wichtig
weil es Leute gibt die erkannt haben
jetzt
vorsichtig verändern jetzt vorsichtige
klimamaßnahmen sind der Garant für
radikale Verschlechterung wir können das
Gestalten jetzt da ist der Text der
Grünen und wir gehen bevor wir
diskutieren an dieser Stelle nochmal zu
Matthias fornhoff der frische Zahlen von
der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen hat vielen
Dank erstmal Matthias und einen guten
Abend man guten Abend in die Runde
guten Abend wie schaut es aus
ja das Schöne an so einem Wahlabend
maybrit ist ja dass man am mit den
Zahlen immer festeren Boden unter die
Füße kriegt das ist jetzt so auch Teil
der Briefwahl sind ausgezählt es kann
sich noch was verändern aber wir sind da
schon auf sehr guten Wege und ich freue
mich auf die nächste Hochrechnung die
kommt hier demnach kommen cdu/csu auf
24,5 Prozent Minus 8,4 Punkte die SPD
26% stärkste Partei gewinnt fünfeinhalb
Punkte dazu die AFD 10,5 mit Verlusten
die FDP 11,7 mit gewinnen die Linke 5%
verliert 4,2 Punkte und es ist absolut
wacklich nach wie vor ob sie reinkommt
in den Bundestag oder nicht falls Sie
noch runter rutscht unter die fünf
Prozent können Sie drei Direktmandate
möglicherweise noch retten die Grünen
bei 13,9% und einer der Wahlsieger
dieses Abends schauen wir uns mal an was
das heißt zum Bilden einer Koalition in
Berlin eine große Koalition hätte
natürlich weiterhin eine Mehrheit 4008
Sitze 3 75 braucht man für Rot-Grün
würde es dann doch relativ deutlich
nicht reichen und auch für Schwarz-Grün
nicht das heißt wenn nicht große
Koalition dann haben wir es mit einer
Dreierkonstellation zu tun SPD mit
Grünen und FDP die Ampel kommt sehr
deutlich über diese Linie die man
braucht absolute Mehrheit hinüber SPD
Grüne und Linke wenn denn die Grünen die
Linke drin wäre schaffte es trotzdem
nicht und jamaika-union Grüne und
fdp-käme auf 45 Sitze das reicht also
wir sehen hier es gibt drei
Konstellationen eine Mehrheit zu bilden
wenn man nicht mit einer
Minderheitsregierung regieren will ja
und dir danken ganz herzlich in der
Runde nochmal für diese Übersicht sollte
in den nächsten 30 Minuten da noch neues
kommen sind wir unter Garantie wieder
bei dir vielen herzlichen Dank und damit
geht es weiter bei Graf lamstow
können Sie noch mal sagen was die FDP
eigentlich auf den Gedanken gebracht hat
so sehr nun für ar Tasche zu plädieren
sie fühlten sich schlecht behandelt in
den jamaika-verhandlungen 2017
und würden sich das mit Angela Merkel
nie vorgestellt haben aber mit Armin
Laschet
die Verhandlung 2017 sind daran
gescheitert dass wir bei den Kernthemen
keinerlei Konzessionen bekommen haben
und deswegen Inhalte nicht durchsetzen
konnten die wir unseren Wählerinnen und
Wählern versprochen haben wir haben das
Gefühl nach den ersten Äußerungen von
Armin Laschet dass er bereit ist an dass
eine Koalition zu führen man muss ja
auch sagen die Konstellation ist eine
andere wir haben es im Grunde mit vier
mittelgroßen Parteien zu tun und wenn
ich das hier mal ganz kurz sagen darf
was Matthias hornhoff gerade an Zahlen
gezeigt hat ist ja in einer Hinsicht
ganz besonders erfreulich nämlich dass
die Extremisten Rechtsaußen und
Linksaußen beide verloren haben und dann
insofern ein Auftrag für eine
Regierungsbildung aus der Mitte heraus
erteilt worden ist und da wir als FDP
auf die Inhalte Wert legen werden wir
schauen was mit Armin Laschet zu
erreichen ist und was mit Olaf Scholz zu
erreichen ist deswegen Frau ellner wenn
sie sagen es hätte ein Plädoyer für
Laschet gegeben nein es gibt ein
Plädoyer für unsere Inhalte es wird die
Gespräche mit den Grünen zuerst geben
und dann werden wir mit den anderen
beiden ich glaube Christian Lindner hat
sehr dezidiert gesagt dass er am
allerliebsten mit der CDU zusammen
regieren würde Robin Alex und er hat
natürlich auch Gründe dafür weil man
sich mit Armin Laschet immer sehr
verbunden fühlte und es dafür eben auch
historische Beispiele gab dass die CDU
diese Partei gut behandelte es ist doch
so es gibt ein rot-grünes Lager und wird
ein schwarz-gelbes Lager und beide haben
diesmal nicht die Mehrheit das heißt
einer muss immer rüberkommen und der
Scham daran ist der darüber kommt der
wird dafür einen hohen Preis aufrufen
können und die Grünen müssen sich jetzt
einfach überlegen wollen Sie diesen
hohen Preis kassieren wenn sie nach
Jamaika kommen und was könnte der sein
und wenn man sich den Grünen Wahlkampf
anguckt was ist die gerade zum Beispiel
gesagt haben kann das ja nur die
Klimapolitik sein so da könnten die
Grünen sagen wir kommen zu euch rüber
aber wir machen eine Klimapolitik die
sich gewaschen hat so und das wäre wenn
man die grüne der grüne Rhetorik folgt
die letzte Wahl wo man überhaupt noch
was machen kann könnte man das ja auch
gut in eigenen WLAN erklären fände ich
schwieriger bei einer Ampel weil
für Christian Lindner hätte er
gesprochen ich komme in die Ampel um das
ganz schlimme Rot-Rot-Grün zu verhindern
aber das gibt's ja jetzt gar nicht also
von daher liegt das Argument er auf der
Seite dass die Grünen sich bewegen und
gar nicht zum Schaden der Grünen sondern
zu nutzen das heißt es gäbe Armin
Laschet es gäbe wahrscheinlich den
Finanzminister Christian Lindner und es
gäbe eine einen grünen Umwelt und
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck wenn
man es mal in köpfend
die grüne Klimapolitik ist schon
dargestellt worden die FDP Klimapolitik
wenn Sie Ihr eigenes Programm ernst
nimmt wo man allerdings beim
klimaanfragezeichen machen kann aber
wenn sie es ernst nimmt ist es auch eine
heftige Klimapolitik dann gucken wir die
CSU an die CSU bei der letzten
jamaika-verhandlung noch ein Quälgeist
der Grünen jetzt bei der Klimafrage war
Söder viel weiter als Laschet so der hat
heute schon gesagt Verbrenner verbiegen
kann ich mir vorstellen 2035
Kohlekraftwerke 20 30 also da könnte es
sein dass man plötzlich von den
beschriebenen vier mittelgroßen hat drei
die den Kanzler zu mehr Klima ziehen
also und wenn man in dieser Logik denkt
kann man das schon sinnvoll erzählen
wir müssen Herr Gabriel uns jetzt helfen
die Ampel zu verteidigen die Ampel ist
natürlich nicht nur immer noch möglich
rechnerisch sondern sie hat ja auch ihre
Faszination oder würden Sie sagen Olaf
Scholz könnte überhaupt eine
rot-grün-rote Regierung angeführt haben
also rot grün rot ganz gewissen nicht
ich meine das sind immer Debatten
gewesen das war so die letzte Patrone
der CDU im Wahlkampf diese Gefahr an die
Wand zu werfen erstens gibt es bei Olaf
Scholz keine Neigung dazu und noch mal
am Ende geht es nicht um arithmetische
Mehrheiten sondern um politische und mit
einer Partei die in Teilen Anti
europäische ist die aus dem Euro in
Teilen raus will und vieles andere mehr
wäre die SPD ganz bestimmt nicht in der
Koalition gegangen die Ampel hat deshalb
eine Chance weil erstens das stimmt
schon die Psychologie dafür spricht
denjenigen der ja wirklich ein
gewaltigen Sieg eingefahren hat jetzt
auch zum Kanzler zu werden ich meine wir
reden jetzt immer über fünf Prozent die
SPD ist über drei Jahre hinweg
verhandelt worden als eine Partei die
bei 14 bis 16 Prozent liegt und jetzt
ist aber 25 und die Union hat einen
gigantischen Einbruch gehabt das spricht
schon manches dafür das zu machen aber
Robin alexander hat recht der
eigentliche Königsmacher oder die
eigentliche königsmacherin sind die
Grünen diejenigen werden das entscheiden
die FDP muss regieren sie kann nicht
noch mal nein sagen das hat sie einmal
zu viel gemacht die Grünen wollen
regieren aber sie haben sozusagen den
größeren Hebel und man wird sehen wo es
wo es darauf hinausläuft und natürlich
geht es um Inhalte es geht aber ganz
bestimmt auch um ein paar Personen es
gibt um politische Positionen es geht um
die Frage wer wird was bis dahin das
würde ich mal vermuten auch die Rolle
wer wird der nächste Bundespräsident
eine Rolle spielen wird also das ein
offenes Spiel für Olaf Scholz spricht
die Psychologie und die Tatsache dass er
wirklich eine gewaltigen Aufholjagd
geschafft hat und Armin Laschet ein
gewaltige Niedergang eine
Mitgliederbefragung hat Kevin kühner
jetzt schon angekündigt in der SPD und
für die SPD Herr Gabriel natürlich fragt
sich der Wähler auch wie Scholz ich wird
das nächste SPD-Fraktion sein und wie
viel Rückendeckung wird dann ein
potenzieller Kanzler haben
naja aber jetzt müssen wir die Kirche im
Dorf lassen wenn die SPD den Kanzler
stellt dann dürfte weil möglich die
Zustimmung zu einer
Koalitionsvereinbarung bei nahe 100%
liegen und wenn die SPD in Kanzler
stellt dann wird auch die Fraktion die
nächsten Jahre jedenfalls sehr stark dem
Kanzler folgen das ändert sich in
Parteien dann manchmal das haben wir
auch eine CDU gesehen aber ich habe
überhaupt keine Sorge das Scholz nicht
die Fraktion sozusagen hinter sich
bekommt und die Partei allemal das ja
für die SPD eine völlig sozusagen
gefühlsmäßig ganz neue Situationen dass
sie endlich aus dem Keller raus ist und
Regierung anführen kann deswegen ja es
wird sicher eine mittlere Abstimmung
geben aber die gewinnt da dann auch mit
nahezu 100%
sagt Sigmar Gabriel wenn sich die
Mitglieder total freuen sagt Frau Meier
gerade das ist vorher schon fest steht
die Hand an die Stirn glauben sie dass
sie zum Verhandlungsteam von Armin
Laschet gehören
das weiß ich nicht das werden wir ja
zusammensetzen
und das wird so sein dass wir gute
Angebote machen in Person und Inhalt das
klingt jetzt antibi also Mitteilung also
das werden wir zusammensetzen wir haben
heute zusammengesetzten im engsten Kreis
in der Konrad adenauer-haus wir haben
die ganze Zeit dort miteinander beraten
es geht morgen früh weiter
und ich glaube dass aus meiner Sicht ist
die Interessenlage der Grünen sehr stark
fokussiert auf das Thema Klima natürlich
und auf die Außenpolitik das sind die
beiden Riesen Themen der Grünen so wie
ich sie wahrnehme
glauben sie er wird sich den
Fraktionsvorsitz nehmen müssen um
politisch zu überleben und nicht noch
mal so eine Situation
ist eine berechtigte Frage und die
Antwort darauf macht deutlich wie wir da
heute zusammengesessen haben wir haben
heute besprochen Präsidium dass es jetzt
bei uns keine interne Frage gibt die
personell entschieden wird sondern wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt auf die
Gespräche mit den Grünen und den
Liberalen und darauf
unsere Projekte in den wichtigsten
Bereichen vorzubereiten und es wird
nichts anderes geben was irgendwie
interne Entscheidung ist sondern wir
sind fokussiert auf die Ermittlung
kriegen wir da ein eine gute
Übereinstimmung hin genau in den
wichtigsten Bereichen glauben sie wird
die CSU auch Ruhe geben oder haben sie
die Furcht des die reinen dann
vielleicht doch nicht mehr so
sind wirklich geschlossen die Frage wie
gehen wir vor dass wir keine jetzt
internen Personalentscheidungen treffen
ist abgestimmt zwischen CDU und CSU sie
haben eben eine inhaltlichen sie haben
eben das innerliche Thema Klima und
Umweltschutz aus der Sicht von Markus
Söder der CSU dargestellt wir sind
inhaltlich und in der Art des vor ist
glaube ich extrem beieinander wir sehen
dass diese Chance besteht wir haben uns
ja um Regierungsverantwortung bemüht die
Möglichkeit ist da sie bei der SPD
leichter Anflüge von Überheblichkeit
auch in der Behandlung von anderen das
ist alles sehr
stolz orientiert das Ergebnis ich glaube
die SPD ist tatsächlich immer noch bei
15 Prozent ich verstehe das alles total
aber bleiben wir noch mal da es gäbe
jetzt natürlich die Möglichkeit auch
Armin Laschet die Schuld an diesem
schlechten Wahlergebnis zuzuschieben und
dann auch natürlich sich auszumalen was
eigentlich im Fall passiert dass er
nicht diese Koalition anführen wird und
Jamaika nicht zustande kommt dann wäre
er nicht nur kein Ministerpräsident mehr
sondern er will kein Kanzlerkandidat
mehr und er wäre wahrscheinlich auch
nicht mehr Parteivorsitzender aber für
die CDU besteht jetzt die Chance ein
gutes Bündnis hinzubekommen aber er
hätte ein Image eines Verlierers ja aber
das ist darum würde ich mir sagen dass
das will es Ihnen nicht sagen nein darum
wir könnten mit solchen Dingen anfangen
sondern sind wir beschäftigt mit
irgendwelchen internen fragen wir sind
beschäftigt damit kriegen wir ein
Bündnis und eine Politik kriegen wir das
hin was Sigmar Gabel genannt hat eine
politische Übereinstimmung aber wer wird
dabei helfen die Ursachen dieses dieser
Wahlniederlage der Union zu analysieren
man kann Armin Laschet dafür die Schuld
geben aber was war es noch aus ihrer
Sicht
es war schon ziemlich also es war es
hatte verschiedene Gründe aber Armin
Laschet ist eigentlich der angeschossene
ex-kanzlerkandidat den wir jetzt haben
den und da können Sie jetzt noch so oft
sagen wie sich stehen wie eine Wand das
hat man bei der Union ja schon oft genug
erlebt dass es dann eben ganz schnell
bröckelt ja und
wenn wir sagen
macht Erhalt aber es liegt nicht daran
dass sie ihren Kanzlerkandidaten so toll
finden den Eindruck habe ich gar nicht
immer sagen wir haben eine
regierungschance und wir haben eine
Aufgabe für die Partei das ist gar keine
Frage das stimmt das muss man auch dazu
sagen dass Norbert Röttgen
wahrscheinlich nicht der größte Fan von
ist und sie
wissen auch sie wüssten auch dass es
durchaus eine Zukunft gäbe wenn Armin
Laschet geben müsste für so wie läuft
das jetzt normalerweise müssen die
Dienstag und Fraktionsvorsitzenden
wählen das werden die vertagen warum
warum nimmt Lasche sich nicht dieses Amt
weil er Angst hat dass er zu viele
Gegenstimmen bekommt und dann schon
schlecht aussieht das kann man aber
nicht ewig vertagen das kann man
dreieinhalb Wochen vertagen bis sich der
Bundestag konstituiert Armin Laschet hat
heute intern gesagt dass er nicht
Oppositionsführer wird das heißt dieser
Mann muss gewinnen der muss
Bundeskanzler werden sonst ist er NRW
Ministerpräsident oder wahrscheinlich
gar nichts das erhöht wieder den Druck
oder den Hebel wie sieht man gabriel
sagte für die Grünen weil bei Laschet
ist es unterschreiben Sie den
Koalitionsvertrag auf der gestrichelten
Linie oder beenden Sie Ihre politische
Karriere so und auch das ist ein
Druckmittel so und so ist die Lage und
die Schuldfrage wird nein die Schuld
wenn er sich ins Kanzleramt rettet dann
ist er erstmal Kanzler und das war doch
auch 2005 auch Angela Merkel hatte einen
schlimmen Wahlkampf 2005 die ist erst
durch die Aggression von Gerd Schröder
in Elefantenrunde wieder ins Spiel
gekommen also wenn er sich ins
Kanzleramt rettet ist es ein neues Spiel
wenn er sich nicht rettet stellt sich
die Schuldfrage nicht da werden sich
alle in der CDU einigen dass er schuld
ist und zwar in zwei Minuten
und
so und dann sind wir noch mal bei Graf
lambsdorf der jetzt auch vor sich hin
schmunzelt Graf Lamsdorf noch mal was
müsste was würde Armin Laschet ihn
anbieten
um was glauben sie muss er den Grünen
anbieten um ein solches Jamaika-Bündnis
möglich zu machen
naja also es ist ja vieles richtiges
gesagt worden ich habe tatsächlich bei
der ein oder anderen Bemerkung
schmunzeln müssen das ist schon wahr
weil wenn wir davon geredet wird dass
die Grünen hier den Hebel in der Hand
haben wir haben ihn gemeinsam in der
Hand die Grünen und die Freien
Demokraten die Grünen sind jetzt bei
13,9 wir sind bei 11,7 das sind 2 %
Punkte unterschied ähm wir wollen
zusammen wir sind zusammen diejenigen
die miteinander reden werden mit wem wir
in welche Gespräche einsteigen oder
ansonsten ist das was hier gesagt worden
ist von vielen das ist ja sehr klug und
sehr richtig für uns ist die
Modernisierung des Staates für uns ist
die Digitalisierung für uns ist das eine
ehrgeizige Steuerreform die wir seit 20
Jahren nicht mehr gehabt haben ein
wettbewerbsfähiges Steuersystem das sind
Themen die für uns interessant sind ein
Klimaschutz der funktioniert und es ist
richtig dass unser Klimaschutzkonzept
anspruchsvoll ist es aber nicht völlig
inkompatibel mit dem der Grünen man kann
darüber reden wie wir das gemeinsam
gestalten bei der Steuer- und
Finanzpolitik wird es ein bisschen
komplizierter aber ich glaube das ist
alles durchaus mit den Ihnen zu
besprechen und dann werden wir
anschließend sehen was Armin Laschet was
Olaf Scholz anbieten mit Armin Laschet
fräule sie haben das eben gesagt
verbindet uns in der Tat die Koalition
in Düsseldorf da gibt es eine
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit das ist
richtig aber es ist völlig unrichtig zu
sagen die Union hätte die FDP immer gut
behandelt oder wenn Herr Alexander sagt
es gibt ja ein Lager nein es gibt kein
Lager also wir sind in der Koalition mit
Frau Merkel untergegangen sogar aus dem
Bundestag geflogen anschließend und in
den jamaika-sondierungen hat Frau Merkel
den Grünen nahezu alles gegeben und uns
praktisch nichts also das ist hier in
irgendeiner Form ein Lager gelbe stimmt
nicht wir sind als FDP ohne
Koalitionsaussage in diese Wahl gegangen
und haben sie gewonnen und jetzt werden
wir in aller Ruhe und ganz gelassen mit
den Grünen die Gespräche aufnehmen und
dann anschließend mit den anderen und
waren das glauben sie alles auch Stimmen
für Christian Lindner oder waren da auch
ein paar Stimmen bei Ihnen bei der FDP
dabei die armen Laschet nicht wählen
wollten das Gegenteil ist der Fall Frau
Illner ich habe in meinem Freundes und
Bekanntenkreis so viele die aus Mitleid
die CDU gewählt haben ich kann ich gar
nicht mehr zählen also wir wären
deutlich besser genau wie die Grünen
deutlich besser gewesen wären wenn es
nicht dieses Kopf an kopfrennen gegeben
hätte zwischen Union und SPD die Grünen
hätten besser abgeschnitten wir hätten
besser abgestimmten das Kopf und
kopfrennen hat noch mal eine gewisse
Dramatik reingebracht und ich habe
whatsapps SMS von Freunden die sich bei
mir entschuldigen sie müssten jetzt die
CDU wählen sie hätten sonst Sorge das
ist Rot-Rot-Grün gibt das ist übrigens
auch eine der sehr guten Nachrichten von
heute Rot-Rot-Grün hat keine Mehrheit da
freue ich mich ganz besonders
aber nur das eben die CDU das immer
getan hätte das kann ich nun wirklich
mit wirklich gut mit historischen
Beispielen belegt widerlegen und das
wird jetzt dann alles besser Graf
Lambsdorff mit welchem Personal wen
glauben Sie wünschen sie sich vielleicht
vor allen Dingen aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
wird ein Friedrich Merz dabei sein oder
ist es dann doch eben Christian Lindner
weil um den Finanzminister kloppen sich
schon alle wird Jens Spahn dabei sein
wird Norbert Röttgen dabei sein Frau
Illner dass sie wissen genau dass sich
diese Frage nicht beantworten werde
sondern ich sage Ihnen das was bereits
klar ist für uns steht im Mittelpunkt
unseres Wahlkampfes Modernisierung des
Staates auch was die Finanzen angeht
deswegen sagt Christian Lindner
beansprucht er für den Fall dass zu
einer Regierungsbildung kommt das
Finanzministerium um klar zu machen dass
das was wir vor der Wahl gesagt haben
nach der Wahl auch umgesetzt wird alles
andere alles andere werden wir sehen und
was bei der Union oder bei irgendwelchen
anderen Parteien personell läuft dazu
sagen wir sowieso gar nichts das ist
Sache das war ja meine Frage richtig und
Herrn Röttgen frage ich jetzt wen von
den Nordrhein-Westfalen glauben sie
könnten dann in einer jamaika-regierung
man als Minister fröhlich begrüßen also
so auch so sie wissen dass wir da
wirklich Liebe fragen mit welchem
Mitleid die FDP jetzt schon Business
nimmt dass die Stimmen
ich fürchte es ein bisschen nächste
Frage das Graf Lambsdorff die falsche
Motivation bei denen vermutet die sich
aus guten Gründen für die CDU und nicht
für die FDP in Bonn entschieden haben
sie haben einen sehr aufgeklärten
politisch informierten
bekanntenkreiskraft lambsdorf das wird
das das wird die Begründung dafür sein
aber wir sehen Sie mal Widerspruch und
dass die dann cdu-gefährdet sind zu
wählen das müssen sie einfach hinnehmen
bei
Inflationsraten natürlich sagen war
ohnehin auch ihr Ideal auch sie waren in
der berühmten pizzakonnection und das
ist ein Modell dass Sie immer schon mal
erwogen haben warum sollte es jetzt
nicht funktionieren da die Frage diese
rhetorische Frage stelle ich warum soll
das jetzt eigentlich nicht funktionieren
also das ist so sowohl die Grünen haben
ihren Beitrag geleistet Frau weißband
aber auch die CDU hat ihren Beitrag
geleistet dass das was jetzt eigentlich
in der Luft lag das ist ein
schwarz-grünes Bündnis gibt rechnerisch
nicht hinkommt das würde ich mal sagen
sind Teil des Wahltages von heute das
ist eigentlich die gesellschaftliche
Situation bitte zwei verlieren ja
Verlierer also die Grünen haben schon
gewonnen das muss man jedes Mal
fairerweise auch anerkennen aber sie
waren in ganz anderen Höhen und sie sind
ganz schön von den Höhen runtergekommen
und wir haben ein größeres Potenzial als
wir geholt haben das sind die beiden wie
soll ich mal sagen das ist das was wir
falsch und vermasselt haben in diesem
Wahlkampf so aber die Kernfrage bleibt
eben genau das wäre das ist schwarz grün
ist das was gesellschaftlich jetzt
eigentlich da ist wir brauchen aber
einen Partner und ich glaube dass
Jamaika nicht dadurch falsch wird dass
die FDP mit Graf Lamsdorf dazu kommt der
Kern bleibt richtig gesellschaftlich
ökologisch außenpolitisch ich meine
Thesen da bitte widersprechen dürfte
die CDU also dieses Land hatte jetzt 16
Jahre lang eine CDU geführte Regierung
es ist was da ist in diesem Land und ich
glaube das merken alle Menschen und ich
glaube das war übrigens Teil ich kann
gerne später in die Analyse gehen warum
die Ergebnisse so sind wir sind aber es
ist Teil der Ergebnisse ich glaube alle
in diesem Land spüren wir stehen vor
einer monumentalen Veränderung und es
gibt Leute die wollen diese Veränderung
und es gibt Leute die haben eher Angst
vor dieser Veränderung aber dass sie
kommt dass sie da sein muss deswegen aus
weiblich ist das spürt jeder ich glaube
nicht dass eine Partei die diese
Gelegenheit hatte und eine Angela Merkel
die seit über 16 Jahren präzise wusste
worum es ging jetzt glaubhaft vertreten
kann dass sie diese Veränderung führen
kann
also das ist natürlich der Lizenz den
wir auch Wahlkampf ausgeführt haben
meine also ich will mich nicht im
Wahlkampf fortsetzen aber wenn sie
wirklich noch mal auf die Punkte gehen
der Kernpunkt bei der Klimafrage der mit
großen Ängsten verbunden ist und die
soziale akzeptanzrate ist offen ist
absolut offen wenn Klima Transformation
bei den Bürgern mit Geld mit höheren
Preisen ankommt dann will ich mal die
nächste Regierung sehen ob sie das
hinbekommt und darum ist das das ein
wirtschaftliches Erfolgsprojekt wird ist
die absolute Überlebensfrage in der
Klimafrage die akzeptanzfrage und die
Frage des wirtschaftlichen Erfolges wir
werden sehr bald sobald die Regierung im
Amt ist wenn wir nicht mehr mit wir
wollen klimaringen alles sondern wird es
darum gehen wie kriegen wir diese
Transformation wirtschaftlich vernünftig
hin und sozial akzeptiert und die Fragen
die sich in der Außenpolitik wir haben
gemeinsame Interessen im Ukraine und
andere da haben wir uns kennengelernt
das wird eine Frage an das
Selbstverständnis Deutschland sein sind
wir bereit zu einer Außenpolitik die
nicht nur freundlich so spricht ja der
CDU ab diese progressive Parteien noch
zu sagen und wenn ich das nur sagen ich
bin wirklich überzeugt nicht nur weil es
mein eigenes Wirken seit Jahren ist und
weil ich meine Partei kenne dieses
durchzutragen von der Außenpolitik ohne
jede Frage ist die CDU
ist die CDU eine geeignete Partei die
das will und die das kann und was der
alle außenpolitischen Fragen anbelangt
bin ich was die SPD anbelangt in
höchster Sorge in aller Österreicher und
eine Frage stellen sind sie denn scharf
auf die Verantwortung denn wenn wir in
den nächsten Jahren große Veränderungen
wollen und manche Leute Angst vor diesen
Veränderungen haben und sie nicht gut
finden werden und zwar egal wie
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich wir dabei
sein werden will die CDU überhaupt die
Partei sein die diese Entscheidungen
trifft und zu diesen Entscheidungen
steht die realistisch das notwendige Tod
weil in letzter Zeit sind die Minister
gerade wenn es um Verantwortung ging er
ausgewichen
das ist eine Zäsur scharf auf diese
Frage meine Einschätzung von diesem
Jahrzehnt es wird ein historisches
entscheidungsjahrzehnt sein und nach
meiner Überzeugung ist die CDU nach wie
vor auch nach der Schwächung die sie
jetzt bei dieser Wahl erfahren hat die
Partei die immer noch viel stärker in
der Breite verankert ist die in dem
personalbereiter aufgestellt ist und
darum glaube ich
jetzt können Sie mir jetzt alles
wirklich mal überzeugen glaube ich ist
sie
unverzichtbar ist sie ist sie ein
wichtiger verantwortungsteil bei dieser
überhaupt war ihre Frage
mit diesem wollen das ist eine riesige
Aufgabe ein ich glaube dass wir noch nie
eine solche Phase vor uns hatten wir
jetzt und die CDU ist die Partei dafür
herauserfinden können und damit sind wir
noch mal bei Sigmar Gabriel in Goslar er
gab aber man kann natürlich die SPD das
genauso fragen ob da liegen
jahrhundertaufgaben jetzt vor der SPD
und es liegen jahrhundertaufgaben vor
diesem Land und es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht weniger brauchen als eine nächste
Agenda wäre denn die SPD dafür bereit
würde sie sich sogar danach sehnen eine
neue agenda-situation lösen zu müssen
wenn Sie das von der SPD-Führung wissen
wollen dann müssen wir die in ihrer
Sendung einladen nicht gehöre nicht dazu
ich kann Ihnen nur sagen dass meine
Vermutung dass die Parteien und zwar
alle über diese großen Herausforderungen
nicht wirklich gesprochen haben ich
meine die Grünen haben zwar über
klimageredet aber das putzigste Plakat
was ich gesehen habe war das gesagt
wurde Wirtschaft Klima ohne Krise ich
meine das sind Plakat wo ich gedacht
habe okay nicht mal die Grünen trauen
sich zu sagen dass das Konflikte mit
sich bringt dass das nicht so einfach
smooth organisiert werden kann und das
liegt glaube ich bei allen Parteien
daran dass sie die Sorge hatten dass sie
nicht widerspruchsfrei ihre Wahlkämpfe
hinkriegen weil die Widersprüche kommen
werden ist noch nicht vermeidbar und
deswegen werden alle Parteien da hat
Herr Röttgens schon recht damit zu tun
haben jetzt sozusagen sich den
Realitäten zu stellen bin übrigens der
Überzeugung dass wir keine 16 Jahre
Regierung mehr erleben werden weil die
Reibungsverluste angesichts dessen was
uns da bevorsteht auch in Regierung sehr
sehr groß sein werden wir haben jetzt
auf einmal ein Parlament da gibt es gar
keine dominierende Kraft mehr da gibt es
zwei Parteien die so ein bisschen über
20 sind drei die sind ein bisschen über
zehn wenn sie meinen Kanzler jetzt
wählen der vielleicht 25 Prozent in
seiner Partei hatte und das auf die
Wahlbevölkerung runterrechnen also wenn
die Nichtwähler dazu nehmen dann hat der
Kanzler nicht mal 20 Prozent der
Bevölkerung hinter sich das wird eine
riesen Herausforderung und ich glaube
Anne alle haben das geahnt die
Sozialdemokraten die Christdemokraten
die Grünen die FDP und deswegen wie soll
ich das freundlich sagen ist man relativ
sparsam damit umgegangen den Menschen zu
sagen was da auf sie zukommt und das
wird jetzt der Fall sein in die andere
Richtung Herr Gabriel also ganz bewusst
hat Olaf Scholz ja nicht ausgeschlossen
dass er auch mit diesem rot-grün-roten
Bündnis
ja also dass er wenigsten mit der
Emotion noch spielt er hat es nicht
ausgeschlossen glauben sie dass ihm das
im Wahlkampf geschadet hat weil es im
Grunde ja der Union erst mal nur möglich
gemacht hat da noch in Wahlkampfthema zu
ziehen das wäre meine Frage Nummer eins
also das Ergebnis das Ergebnis spricht
dagegen er hat ja ein gutes Ergebnis
bekommen und es gibt einfach für diese
Behauptung der SPD ginge im Zweifel auch
mit der Linkspartei gibt es weder bei
Scholz eine Projektionsfläche der ist
und das Gegenteil einer solchen
Koalition das sind sozial-liberaler ich
glaube übrigens dass die grüne Sonne
mitgemacht hätten ein Teil ihrer
Wählerschaft kommt doch inzwischen aus
der bürgerlichen und konservativen Teil
der Gesellschaft die wir sie sofort
wieder los gewesen und im übrigen wüsste
ich nicht woher sozusagen die politische
Mehrheit hätte kommen sollen die SPD
kann eigentlich mit einer Partei
mitgehen die im Zweifel zwei Parteien
sind eine ganz realzug politische in
Ostdeutschland und alles was so an
linkem
Strom läuft in Westdeutschland sie
wissen ja gar nicht mit wem sie da
eigentlich regieren also das ist glaube
ich hat nicht gezogen und nimmt auch
keiner wirklich ernst eigentlich wollte
es wahrscheinlich nur die Linke die
Frage war ja warum hat es Olaf Scholz
nicht ausgeschlossen aber wir fragen
noch mal Robin alexander war es in ihren
Augen Herr Alexander ein Fehler damit
überhaupt gegeben hätte so lange zu
spielen er hat ja nicht damit gespielt
also die SPD hat zweiter nein das ist
unfair finde ich die SPD hat 2013
Parteitagsbeschluss gemacht die Linke
muss sich zur NATO beginnen heute alles
Scholze 700 Mal erzählt so und das war
ja damals die Idee dass ich die Linke in
diese Richtung entwickelt und die
Klügeren Leute in der Linken Wolken das
auch nur die haben das nicht geschafft
also die Linke hat sich in den letzten
Jahren programmatisch zurückentwickelt
also kluge Abgeordnete der Linken Stefan
Liebig kluge Außenpolitiker der hat
Mitte der längs naturperiode seinen Sitz
im Auswärtigen Ausschuss fassungslos von
sich geworfen
ja also die Linke hat einfach diese
Entwick noch nicht gemacht so und und
damit war das Faszination in der SPD für
die für ein linkes Bündnis
ein progressive Koalition und es gibt
Teile die Jusos die da jetzt in den
Bundestag kommen der Kevin Kühnert hat
jetzt 50 bis 60 Jusos in der Fraktion
die sind alle in Opposition zur
groko-sozialisiert die haben alle die
nur olaf-kampagne mitgemacht die hören
alle auf seinen Kommando der braucht
doch gar keine Linkspartei der kann doch
seine eigene linke Opposition zu Olaf
Scholz machen die Linkspartei hat doch
die historische Funktion verloren die
die DDR Nostalgie macht jetzt die AFD
und das was man an Reform
Sozialdemokratie macht das kann die SPD
auch selber machen also es gibt einfach
den Sinn für diese Parteien nicht mehr
wir sind bei der Frage gleich Frau
Weißwein wir sind bei der Frage noch mal
auf die andere Seite wer den Bürgern
jetzt eigentlich die CDU hat es in
diesem Wahlkampf nicht getan sagen wird
in einer solchen Koalition in einem
solchen Bündnis wir verstehen
jahrhundertaufgaben vor uns das wird
viel Geld kosten es wird große
Verteilungskämpfe geben und es wäre dann
eben die Sozialdemokratie nicht dabei
die sagt das muss sozial abgefedert
werden wir fordern den Mindestlohn wir
sagen die reichen sollen sich mehr daran
beteiligen als die die kein Geld haben
das haben die auch gesagt richtig das
geht jetzt aber alles weg und es würde
Weg marschieren wenn wir Ihren Planspiel
folgen sie dürfen die Grünen dürfen
Klima satt machen und schwarz und gelb
würden eben die Wirtschaft und den
restlichen ich glaube nicht dass das ein
Thema ist von Sozialleistungen weil das
müssen doch Leute machen die
Facharbeiter sind die gut verdienen das
sind doch nicht Leute die ihnen Hartz IV
gefahren sind und da ist wirklich ein
interessanter Punkt Armin Laschet hat
immer Michael wassiliadis zitiert in
seiner Kampagne den Chef der IGBCE und
er wollte ausgreifen auf dieses
facharbeitermilieu weil er eben dachte
die SPD bindet das nicht mehr das ist
auch schlau weil diese Leute müssen die
Energiewende ja mitmachen nur jetzt gibt
es die näher wieder und natürlich ist
die das facharbeitermilieu traditionell
real eher bei der SPD und die haben doch
auch die letzten großen Reformen
getragen wer hat denn die Agenda gemacht
die Agenda ist gemacht worden von
Sozialdemokraten erdacht worden von IG
Metallern also von also das was sie
sagen was ich merke nie getraut hat dass
er die SPD vorher gemacht deshalb wäre
ja das interessante ob man jetzt in
diesem Jamaika diese Milieus beteiligen
kann und das wäre tatsächlich eine
Aufgabe wie macht man das aber für diese
Beteiligung dieser Milieus braucht es
Beziehungsarbeit vor Ort ja es braucht
damit Kinder gleiche Bildungschancen
haben Wort Beziehungsarbeit würden sie
da glaube ich nicht auf weil die die
möchten anders adressiert werden das
sind keine Kinder das sind keine Kinder
ich bin aber nun mal jemand der arbeitet
in diesem Bereich da spricht man nun mal
so da komme ich nicht aus meiner Haut
aber es geht um die Box
schauen Sie das ist doch das ganze
Problem des grünen Wahlkampfs gewesen
sie hatten eine Menge Zustimmung und sie
haben das mit der Art sind die Leute
adressieren verloren und jetzt sagen Sie
ich spreche nun mal mit Kindern
und zwar mein Punkt ist wir werden
Investitionen brauchen wir werden
Investitionen öffentliche
Infrastrukturen machen das ist kein
Puzzlespiel wir können nicht grüne
Klimapolitik machen und FDP
Wirtschaftspolitik weil das nicht
zusammenpasst weil das in sich
widersprüchlich ist wir werden um genau
diese Leute mitzunehmen um die Schere
zwischen Arm und Reich zu schließen das
sind Facharbeiter
ich spreche von der Schere zwischen arm
und reicht immer weiter aufgeht in
diesem Land was zu Spannungen so
politischen Spannungen und auch dazu
dass unsere Demokratie immer schwächer
funktioniert weil unsere sozialen
Systeme auseinanderbrechen unsere
Kommunen auseinanderbrechen und das
liegt auch daran dass wir die Menschen
am schlechtesten bezahlen die die
verantwortungsvollste Arbeit machen und
zwar vor Ort und zwar ja auch mit
Kindern und auch mit den Ärmsten um
diese Menschen einzubinden und hier
einfach nur weil die Linke nicht in
dieser Runde ist das ist das was die mit
an den Tisch bringen würde und das ist
das was die Grünen vertreten und das ist
das Element dass ich für eine gelungene
Zukunft und um uns als Gesellschaft
zusammenhängend mitzunehmen und nicht
nur die die durch die Automatisierung
ihre Jobs noch behalten dafür braucht es
soziale Politik und darauf können wir
nicht versuchen damit sind wir noch mal
bei Graf Lamsdorf nämlich genau bei
diesem Punkt wie wichtig wird es sein
Graf Lamsdorf die Menschen mitzunehmen
ihnen nicht zu sagen aus der
Klimakatastrophe können wir uns
herauserfinden und parallel dazu
schaffen wir auch noch die
Schuldenbremse und parallel dazu werden
wir auch noch die Steuern senken wie
sehr glauben sie wird auch die FDP
beschnitten in einer Jamaika-Koalition
wenn man miteinander redet wird jede
Partei Dinge durchsetzen wollen und bei
anderen Punkten Konzession machen aber
mir ist eines hier ganz wichtig und das
ist etwas was mir wo ich manchmal wir
wünschen würde Frau Weißmann wird so ein
bisschen aus den Wahlkampfmodus
rauskommen wenn man über Klimapolitik
redet dann können es nicht nur grüne
Ansätze sein und es kann auch nicht das
einzige Thema der neuen Bundesregierung
sein am Wahlkampf stand er fährt man das
völlig andere Themen die Menschen mehr
bewegen also Verkehr und Mobilität
wie geht es weiter in den Schulen was
läuft mit der Digitalisierung das wissen
sie arbeiten ja aber sie ist doch sie
ist doch genau auf diesen Punkt
eingegangen
also es ist einfach so dass wir haben
eine Diskurs hier als ob wir alles und
ausschließlich nur durch das Klima
Prisma betrachten dürfen und da hat Herr
Alexander völlig Recht wenn er sagt für
Facharbeiter die man dabei mitnehmen
will muss man andere Politikfelder
mitdenken eine starke Wirtschaft in der
die gute Jobs und anständige Bezahlung
bekommen das gehört dazu wir brauchen
deswegen völlig andere Ansätze wir
brauchen ein ein breiteren Ansatz wenn
wir mit einer Bundesregierung ein Land
von 83 Millionen sehr unterschiedlichen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern regieren wollen
und deswegen nochmal ich glaube es ist
gut und richtig dass wir miteinander in
Gespräche gehen aber wir müssen aufhören
sozusagen die eigene Dogmatik vor uns
her zu tragen wenn demonstrans dann wird
es nicht funktionieren sondern wir
müssen bereit sein auch den anderen
zuzuhören ihre Prioritäten zu erkennen
und ernst zu nehmen dann können wir
konstruktiv miteinander verhandeln aber
dazu müssen wir eben rauskommen aus
einem wahlkampfdrucktus wie ich das
jetzt hier die letzten paar Minuten so
gehört haben ich glaube wir müssen
trotzdem anders miteinander reden an
welcher Stelle würden Sie denn Herr Graf
lambsdorf diese Türen öffnen und aus dem
Wahlkampfmodus rauskommen also wir
wissen dass die Schuldenbremse ein
dictum ist von Christian Lindner über
das er nicht diskutieren wird wie ist
das oder ist es das schon nicht mehr
sagen sie auch am Ende kann es gute und
schlechte Investitionen geben es kann
welche geben die sind innovativ und
gehen eben
investiv und es kann eben Subventionen
geben die sind eher konsumitiv und wenn
es gute Investitionen sind dann sind es
auch gute Schulden also konsumtive
Investitionen Frau Illner die haben Sie
exklusiv ja das stimmt
das ist okay nein also worüber wir reden
und dass das wirklich entscheidende wir
wollen ein wettbewerbsfähiges
Steuersystem das privates Kapital für
Investitionen mobilisiert wir wollen
ordentliche Steuereinnahmen aus einer
starken Wirtschaft für die öffentlichen
Investitionen die wir brauchen um unsere
sozialpolitischen unsere
umweltpolitischen Ziele zu erreichen wir
schaffen das alles nur auf der Grundlage
einer starken Wirtschaft und deswegen
ist es mehr als ein Klischee wenn wir
sagen als FDP wir denken ans
erwirtschaften bevor wir über das
Verteilen reden wir reden auch über das
Verteilen wir reden auch darüber dass
wir eine große Transformation der
Gesellschaft Richtung Klimaneutralität
vor uns haben wo sie sich vorstellen
könnten dass die FDP ein Türchen ein
bisschen öffnen würde weil sie ja gerade
den anderen vorwarfen dass sie noch im
Wahlkampf sind wir merken dass die FDP
daran auch noch ein bisschen arbeitet
wenn ich das so sagen darf und wir
fragen uns wir fragen uns Sigmar Gabriel
in einer letzten Runde was glauben Sie
worauf wird es hinauslaufen und wie
lange wird es dauern mal der Blick in
die Schneekugel
also ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt
dass die Psychologie dafür spricht dass
es am Ende der Ampel wird unter der
Führung von Olaf Scholz aber natürlich
haben alle die die Recht die sagen es
gibt eine große Schnittmenge inhaltlich
zwischen CDU und FDP
es wird sehr darauf ankommen wie weit
die beiden Parteien den Grünen
Entgegenkommen können und diese beiden
Dinge werden jetzt in den nächsten
Wochen ausgehandelt aber das haben wir
im Grunde jetzt den ganzen Abend über
besprochen das ist letztlich um die
Frage geht wer kriegt da die meisten
inhaltlichen Überschneidungen hin ich
bin nicht so sicher dass es wirklich so
lange dauert also wenn das ernst gemeint
ist dann kann man das relativ schnell
rausfinden und dann wird man nicht
wieder ein halbes Jahr verhandeln müssen
meine Hoffnung wäre schon dass wir
Weihnachten wissen wer dieses Land
regiert denn wir haben daraufhin hat
Herr Röttgen zurecht hingewiesen so
gewaltige Aufgaben in Europa vor uns
dass ein mehr monatiger Ausfall der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland dem Kontinent
Schaden wird zumal Frankreich auch in
den Wahlkampf geht wenn wir jetzt alle
nur auf den eigenen Bauchnabel gucken
dann wird es gefährlich und deswegen
hoffe ich dass wir Ende des Jahres eine
Regierung haben wer immer die dann
stellen wird
Frau Meier ihr Tipp
ich hoffe auch dass es sehr schnell geht
und ich habe im Moment einfach dieses
alle machen die Räume weit und eng
zugleich also alle Muskeln sich jetzt
auf und
bieten sich an
und es ist eben einfach dieser Wahlabend
heute und dann ich würde da im Moment
kein keine Wette eingehen nur im Privat
okay und sie denken das am Ende Jamaika
durchaus auszuverhandeln und
abzuverhandeln wäre mit dem
Bundespräsidialamt für Katrin
Göring-Eckardt ist sowas vorstellbar für
Sie also das habe ich nicht gesagt ich
finde dass man irgendwie eine Person
glücklich macht und ihre Partei stolz
sollte nicht keine Grundlage sein für
Koalitionsverhandlungen sagen wir es mal
so das ist auch ein klarer Satz Norbert
Röttgen was wird es am Ende und wie
lange dauert's es ist wirklich offen ich
hoffe es kommt jetzt der ernste Lage in
die Gespräche rein wovon ich ausgehe und
damit ist es eine ganz neue Lage neben
der politischen Übereinstimmung wird es
eine Vertrauensfrage sein dass man sich
wechselseitig das zutraut und ich glaube
auch ja genau absolut und ich glaube
auch dass alle wissen wir auf uns
schauen nicht nur die deutschen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger was wichtig ist
sondern auf uns wird geschaut dass
Deutschland seine Verantwortung schnell
nachkommt und darum wird das in diesem
Jahr glaube ich zu einem zu einem
Ergebnis kommen und nicht Fasching erst
was sagt Marina weiß man
meine Hoffnung ist eine Ampel mit einer
sozialen klimafreundlichen und digital
fortschrittlichen Politik für
Deutschland
das weiß ich nicht gut wissen wir alle
nicht so richtig Robin Alexander ich
würde die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben dass
der Wahlkampf wurde von so vielen Seiten
vermasselt dass da denkprozessor
einziehen und die
sondierungsverhandlungen nicht
vermasselt werden und dann wird Jamaika
und Markus Söder aus Bayern wird welche
Rolle übernehmen
bayerischer Ministerpräsident wir
bleiben nein ich meine aber in diesem
Verhandlungen welche Rolle spielen er
hat doch heute schon gesagt er freut
sich immer darum Koalitionsausschuss zu
fahren und dann kann er doch mit den
Grünen gemeinsamen Armin Lasche zu mehr
Klimaschutz treiben das macht den
bestimmt Spaß da würde ich mir gar keine
Sorgen machen so und dann sind wir bei
Alexander Graf Langsdorf ihr Tipp Graf
Land zu
ich tippe heute Abend nicht ich wünsche
mir was ich wünsche mir eine Regierung
in der wir viele Inhalte durchsetzen
weil es ist auch klar dass wir es
schnell machen müssen das ist richtig
Frankreich Welt im April Amerika Welt im
November wir sind nicht allein auf der
Welt und es wird ein Jahrzehnt der
Entscheidungen wie Norbert Röttgen
gerade richtigerweise gesagt haben nicht
nur fürs Klima sondern auch für die
Freiheit international sagen ich frage
Sie diese ampelkäme für sie gerade heute
Abend gar nicht in Frage ich habe das am
Anfang sehr deutlich gemacht dass wir
mit allen Reden werden auch mit oder
Scholz und den Sozialdemokraten
vollkommen klar gut dann haben wir das
wenigstens noch festgehalten dass sie
auf jeden Fall reden ich darf mich ganz
herzlich bedanken für diese Stunde hier
heute abend es ist ein spannender Abend
es bleibt einer es wird eine irre Woche
und es werden verrückte Wochen und wir
alle können sagen wir sind in
höchstspannung dabei vielen lieben Dank
für Ihr Interesse für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit danke für die Debatte
hier und im ZDF geht es weiter mit einem
heute journal Spezial und wir sehen uns
wenn Sie mögen kommenden wieder um 22
Uhr 15 bleiben sie heute legen Sie
tschüss vielen Dank
[Musik]